yah
[Music]
the prayers were held at a park outside
the Al Noor mosque which was a target of
the shootings this comes a day after the
government announced a sweeping plan to
ban semi-automatic and military-style
weapons by next month an australian 28
year old has been charged with one
murder following the attacks
police say further charges will follow
well the families of the victims are
still trying to come to terms with that
attack DW spoke to the mother of one of
those who was killed let's Andy analysts
here that's Sonny let's analyse cheok
hee Aroha or after a ship reacted heard
about this is Jonny Esat mother of
Hussein al omari who was killed in
Christchurch this is one of the last
photos of the 35 year old with his
sister aya he went to Friday prayer that
day and never came back
Cabala beyond Canada okay now Sharon
Suraj Dida can 400 then my mama say are
mabrook we are on Weibo is via Vittorio
Arriba El Feroz multa de la máquina
Narayana Farah Malta can relieve Shui
Xer Manila's only Nicole
oh hi cars ro dah he can it's Fairland
Farallon haven't haven't happened Johnny
found out from eyewitness accounts that
her son tried to tackle the terrorist
foreign foreign evany calm your Cavalli
II read Yahoo Liz Lemon now it viable
Arabs ooh la bamba linguistically get
out what you are doing here but the yer
cover sin Alcatel al khattab a masala
for under a label wobble mineral verses
[Music]
the Solidarity of New Zealanders after
the attack has helped to ease Jana's
pain mahakala come ha ha aluminous
behave hack Thomas off my sarama mama
can hack tell Makani little she be less
mineral water do an annoucement in Dacia
Allah yeah he had a mock of tappable
Jorah he lives Audrey all those
memorials so important for so many
people for more let's go directly to
Christchurch in DWS Samantha early
standing by for us good day to you
Samantha commemorations not only
confined to Christchurch can you tell us
about the national moment of silence and
and what else was happening this was
truly a national day of remembrance
the moan of silence at 1:30 it was
broadcast on the major television and
radio networks all through the country
the call to prayer really people
stopping nationwide there were also
human chains formed around several
mosques right across the country
and the idea behind that was people
wanted to show that the Muslims inside
could pray safely
there were haka those very powerful very
powerful moly dancers the also other
other vigils these vigils tonight as
well across the country this weekend too
and several mosques also open their
doors to anyone who wanted to come in
and pray so really yeah really really a
real sense of national mourning and
national remembrance together one week
on there were also New Zealand women who
wore head Scouts today as an act of
solidarity with Muslim women a
Samantha's a result of the attacks one
week ago today New Zealand's government
has announced a sweeping ban on
semi-automatic and assault weapons in
New Zealand
will this be taken up by Parliament has
there been any debate on the move
this is really an initiative that has
had a cross-party support I don't see
any issue at all with it getting through
Parliament it's going to be a very quick
process there is about one week for
public submissions and but the major
lobby groups federated farmers and the
Police Association
yeah the two major groups here in New
Zealand have both come out in support of
it there has been some concern about the
pace of the changes and that was raised
especially by the single member of the
Act party
doomsy moi and he's concerned that the
changes are happening just very quickly
and not enough time for consultation so
there has been that concern raised but
it appears that the changes have very
very poor support cross-party support
and they should face no problem getting
through Parliament okay now as a result
of the attacks as well there's been
pressure on social media Australia's
backing New Zealand's call for a global
crackdown on social media after the
Christchurch gunman live-streamed that
atrocity what does Prime Minister
Jacinta Arden want to see happen briefly
if you could well this week she said
earlier this week really what she wanted
accountability in one word and this past
day you'd expect that she's really been
focusing on the morning and remember
inside and being with the families but
we can expect to I think here more on
what they expect from Facebook and other
social media companies very soon DW
Samantha early in Christchurch thank you
very much